[Music]
hello you took just love us in my
friends this is grunge in here welcome
to the 17th episode of my chest strap
series in the recent world rapid and
blitz championship London system was one
of the most popular preferred choice by
many super gems including magnus carlsen
due to its easy piece layout rock-solid
structure and clear middle game plans
this opening reached to the new heights
and a great popularity boom so that's
why it's very important for you to have
a good line against it now the line I'm
going to recommend in this video not
only contain a good trap but it is one
of the most preferable choice of the
black and the good point is even though
if you open and doesn't fall for the
trap you still obtain a very good
position with all the very chances in
the middle game the London system arises
after the following order white plays d4
now whether here you are playing Knight
to f6 or defy doesn't matter let's say
in this game black start with the move
Knight to f6 Knight to f3 and after the
move defy and push up to f4 we reach the
starting point of the London system now
in this game black immediately played c5
but my original recommendation is you
should always play the movie 6 first
before committing the c5 because we want
to avoid any other complications ok see
Phi III Knight to c6 c3 and only now
black plays the movie 6 so giving
protection to the c5 square white
continue with the move Knight B to d2
and black plays the move Bishop to d6
the mainline continue with the move
Bishop to g3 so in case black captures
the g3 Bishop then white will recapture
with the Ashbourne
and in that case the H file will open up
for the white rook so it's very obvious
that black shouldn't take that bishop
and instead of that he should castle on
the Kings side white place
to d3 and now we reach one of the most
critical position of the game now as I
have I'd like to do here blacks main
choice are p6 and Queen to e7 but I'm
not going to recommend any of them
instead of that I'm going to recommend a
very tricky move rook to e8 and
immediately white needs to be careful
and has to play the accurate move Knight
to e5 in my own blitz games I have seen
even some hiring players are not paying
attention and they routinely castle at
this point but I think this is already a
mistake because black can capture this
bishop and after ash captures black and
achieve this freeing break ePHI which
not only give him the center but also
provide great attacking potential now
just to highlight the problems in the
white cam I like to show you my quickest
win in this line where here my opponent
decided to capture the e5 pawn I already
captured with my knight and now he take
this 9 in order to get a tempo on the
roof with the move Knight to f3 ok I
played Bishop to g4 so pinning that
night my opponent plays Bishop to e2
renewing the trend and I place my rook
to the most aggressive square rook to
edge file seeing the King side attack is
looming my opponent try to exchange some
pcs so he played night to d2 hitting the
bishop I take this bishop and after
Queen captures I played a very cunning
Queen transition move which start with
the following water that is Queen to b6
hitting the b2 my opponent defended with
the move rook to d1 and now I played
Queen to e6 so my idea is to play d4 as
that Queen is unprotected so my opponent
give the support with the move rook to
even but then black reveal his original
idea Knight to g4 and now I think there
is no stopping on Queen 2 at 6:00
in chess if you create mating threads
then sometimes you open and really
panics and made mistakes and this is
exactly happen over here because my
opponent was already feeling
uncomfortable and in desperation he
tried this move that is f3 which turns
out as a big time blunder before I move
on I like you to pause this video and
find out what is the winning
continuation for the black I hope you
find this wonderful move BAM poor white
king ha ha ha well why doesn't have any
choice white has to capture this rook
but then comes the very simple sequence
that is Queen check King to Jeevan Queen
chat King to have fun and queen h1 is a
checkmate
so it is very obvious that white cannot
casually castle at this position but he
has to play Knight to e5 which is in
fact the main line in this position here
black should immediately capture this
Knight and now it doesn't matter how
white is going to recapture for example
if your opponent plays Bishop captures
Aoife then the simplest is you take this
bishop and after pawn captures and
Knight to d7 we almost reached the same
trappy position the man who in this
position is d captures ePHI afterwards
black should play the move Knight to d7
attacking ePHI and now there are two
ways you can support this ePHI Square
when I was checking this position in the
online database I found out this
interesting scenario where Knight to f3
in this position has been played 19
times + f4 has been played 19 times and
both in 2016 but let me tell you one
thing one of them has a right move and
another one leads to the trap so the big
question is if you are in this position
as a white how you are going to continue
ok I hope you didn't consider the move
f4 because this leads to the blunder
house and exactly what black wants
I just like to briefly mention that if
white plays moves such as a knight to f3
or Queen to B 1 then I have attached a
simple line which is available in the
description which will give you a very
good idea how black should continue from
here onwards ok so let's see what's
wrong with the more f4 after all it
looks very natural it's supporting the
center and what can be the wrong well
the problem can be highlighted by blacks
next to move first
c4 hitting the bishop doesn't matter
that Bishop goes
in this game white plays Bishop to c2
and now can you see it yep it's going to
be six attacking to sports and funny
enough white cannot defend both of them
so just within 12 moves black is going
to win an important pawn and that is
more than enough to decide the game
let's see a few moves further which will
show you how white position completely
crumble after losing an important point
the best move in this position is castle
on the Kings side
afterwards it's worth to remember that
never take III pawn but always take the
b2 b1 s this is the only pawn grabbing
move which gives black and advantage in
fact the trap doesn't stop over here if
I doesn't continue with the careful
moves then game can be finished very
very quickly I reached this position in
a rapid game against a 2,200 rated
player where my opponent continued with
the move rook to Sivan so his idea is if
black foolishly captured the c3 pawn
then Bishop to at 7 and white NAB the
black Queen so obviously I didn't fall
for that cheapo I played a stronger move
that is g6 so not only stopping the
bishop check but I'm also stopping
further advancement of that F pawn my
opponent continue with the mu e 4 so he
desperately want to attack my pawn chain
the correct continuation over here is
Knight to d6 and now my opponent
responded with the MU earful so his idea
is very simple he just want to attack my
night and then pressurizing the d5
square here I responded with the MU D
for attacking the c3 and blunting the
diagonal of the bishop now if my
opponent responded with the MU fi then
after D cap to c3 black obtained a very
good position so in the game he decided
to capture this D pawn and after I
captured with mine
now he responded with the mu K Phi so at
first sight this looks very threatening
because white is attacking of an ID but
in fact white has overlooked important
tactic in the position which we are
about to see before I move on I like you
to pause this video and find out an
amazing resource which gives black of
winning advantage okay I hope you find
this wonderful blow boom hahaha
so not only black is grabbing the whole
roof but black is also threatening the
c2 bishop so wide response is force why
it has to take this Queen but after the
man with this jack not only black regain
his queen but black obtain a clear
winning advantage my opponent played a
captures b6 but after Knight to d3
he simply resigned because if you
carefully look at this position on black
is up in exchange and upon and why
doesn't have any clear-cut compensation
well I hope you enjoy and long this
wonderful trap against London system
remember at this position f4 is a big
time blunder due to the MU c4 and given
to b6 which will not only give black a
clear-cut pawn but if white doesn't play
accurate moves then as we seen in my
game black and quickly around a full
point well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care
one of my appalling play here Bishop d7
and this is a big blunder
I wonder if you can spot amazing over
here this trap has been occurred 116
times where black players average elo is
more than 2,300 very surprising but it
is true